Good morning. It's good to see everybody. I strategically picked the 4th of July
weekend so nobody would be here, but you guys showed up. So thank you. I want to
say first of all that I am a teacher, not a preacher. So a couple
consequences that means for us. First of all, if I get into teacher mode and
ask a question, it's not a rhetorical question you can answer.
The other is that I taught at the college level for over 20 years and so college
classes are either 50 minutes or 75 minutes. So the Kirkland said the movie's
gonna go for what, an hour or more? So we'll see how it goes. But thank you.
We're looking at Psalm 8 this morning. We finally got to Psalm 8 after five
chapters of lament. We get to Psalm 8 and I think Brandon had mixed emotions
letting me have Psalm 8 because he had to labor through the
5 lament Psalms. But just to let you know we're gonna finish Psalm 8 and
then we're gonna go into five more that are lament Psalms as well mostly. And so
but as we start I want to put two images in your mind. One of them, most of you
here are our parents and you can remember a time when your young child was
sick and maybe has a fever and you're rocking them. And I distinctly remember
this even though it was many many years ago, my kids are turning 40 now, but I
distinctly remember the times of rocking a sick child, their warm body up
against me and I distinctly remember the thought that this child was helpless
and totally dependent on us. And it was an absolutely scary thought. I thought we
were adults. We were very young. But I thought we were adults and we could
handle this thing, but it was just very scary. So that's one image.
The second one I want you to think about walking out. We've all walked out
on a nice clear night and seen the moon and the stars and the beauty. I remember
recently we did it, we got up in the middle of the night to see when they
had that odd northern lights, right? And so some of us we went out in the middle
of the night to try to see it. And I remember going out and it was a
clear night and seeing the stars and the moon. And I have enough science
background and you all have taken enough science to know our universe is huge,
right? And when we stand out and look at it often, we think that we are very
insignificant. We're just a speck on this earth, which is a speck in the
universe. And sometimes we can feel very insignificant and small. So I want
you to keep those images in your mind as we look at Psalm 8 because Psalm
8 is going to is going to deal is kind of bring those images to our mind. So
let's let's read Psalm 8 first. Oh Lord, our Lord, how majestic is your name
and all the earth. You have set your glory above the heavens out of the
mouth of babies and infants. You have established strength because of your
foes to still the enemy and the Avenger. When I look at the heavens
and the work of your fingers, the moon and the stars, which you have
set in place. What is man that you are mindful of him and the Son of man that
you care for him? Yet you have made him a little lower than the heavenly
beings and crowned him with glory and honor. You have given him dominion
over the works of his hand of your hands and you have put all things
under his feet, all sheep and oxen and also the beasts of the field and
the birds of the heaven and the fish of the sea, whatever passes
along the paths of the seas. Oh Lord, our Lord, how majestic is your name
in all the world. This is the word of the Lord.
Let's pray. Dear Lord, we thank you so much for this time to gather to
encourage one another. I pray that I will get out of the way and allow
your word to change the hearts of all who are here in Jesus name. Amen.
Since we've been going through the Psalms here and we're going to be doing
this, I guess for what, 10 years? 11 maybe? I thought it would be
important for us to get some context here about Psalm 8 and you'll see
why this is important as we get to Psalm 8. I grew up thinking
that the Psalms were just a random collection of poems, songs. It
didn't matter what order they were in. You could just step in and read one.
I still do that sometimes. If I want to have a particular way I'm
thinking, I'll step in and read a song. So 150 of them written by
David and others. At some point, I was introduced to the fact that
it's not a random collection of poems that somehow they're
organized into themes. These themes weave their way through the
book of Psalms as they're grouped together. So David and others wrote the
Psalms but it's clear that sometime later that there were editors. Most
Old Testament scholars believe that there were editors that organized
the Psalms in a way that into these themes as you weave through
these poems and songs. The most obvious organization you can see is
if you look at your Bible you can see that they're organized into
books but we have the introductory two Psalms, Psalm 1 and 2, which
introduce themes that are going to be throughout the Psalms and then
you have these groups of five groups of Psalms. Brandon and
Luke did a good job of walking through Psalm 1 and 2 to cover these topics
and Psalm 1 talks about the meditation on God's Torah, his word, and
Psalm 2 talks about the coming of the anointed one, the Messiah. And
those themes are going to come throughout the Psalms. So this
summer we're covering part of book 1. So book 1 is Psalm 3 through
41 and we're covering a portion of that, Psalm, the introductory
Psalm 1 and 2 and then through Psalm 14. Many scholars have
identified that within book 1 in that 3 to 41 that there are certain
groups of Psalms that have themes. And we're grouping one of
them. So book 3 or Psalm 3 through 14 is considered a group of Psalms
that have a theme associated with them. And that's why Brandon chose to
do through Psalm 14 so we could get this grouping. Now what I
want you to see is that Psalm 8 sits right in the center of this
grouping. So you have five Psalms, Psalm 3 through 7 that are kind of
lament in orientation. You have Psalm 8 and then you have Psalm 9
through 14 with another five that are lament in orientation. So we
see this organization could give us an idea of Psalm 8 and its
importance in explaining this group and what's going on in these
Psalms. Old Testament scholars have suggested there's a reason that
for this organization that Psalm 8 puts into context what we're
reading in the five before and the five after and what we're
going to see in the next five weeks. So let's kind of think how
this works. So Psalm 2 that Luke talked about talks about the
Messiah that the nations, kings and nations are raging against
Yahweh and His anointed one, His Messiah. And we learn that the
response to this Yahweh sets up Messiah who is a king and a son
in Zion and says this king will break them with a rod and dash them
to pieces. So this is a clear picture of a victorious king. So we
go right from that Psalm 2 into Psalm 3 and all of a sudden you
have the king, the anointed one of God and what's he doing? He is
on the run from His son no less. And so we see over the next
successive Psalms David who's the anointed king not in a
victorious symbol but he's calling out to God because he's
surrounded. Psalm 4 David's calling out to Yahweh into distress.
Psalm 5 David calls out to Yahweh in his groaning because of
bloodthirsty enemies. Psalm 6 David asks Yahweh to deliver his
life from his many foes. And Psalm 7 David pleads for Yahweh to
save him from his enemies. So after Psalm 2 when we would
expect to see Psalms of victory, victorious king, we don't. We
see a king on the run surrounded by his enemies. So now we come
to Psalm 8. And so Psalm 8 is going to put this seeming
disconnect between what we saw in Psalm 2 and now what we're
seeing in these lament Psalms. It's going to take this
disconnect and explain why that is in God's plan. So Psalm 8
starts and ends with the same phrase. Oh Lord, our Lord, how
majestic is your name in all the earth. So a couple things
about this phrase. Something you may know but I didn't know
okay that when you read this in the Bible you see that the
first Lord is in all capital letters. Okay if you see this in
your Bible it'll show it in all capital letters and the second
Lord is in upper and lower case. Now there's a reason for that
and you know when we go from Hebrew to English we're going to
lose some things. The Lord in all capital letters you may
know is when you see that that's Yahweh that's the name
of God that God gave himself at the burning bush. And the
second one, the second Lord, the upper and lower case, is the
word Adonai which is a descriptor. It means Lord or master. So
really we read this, oh Yahweh, our Lord, how majestic is
your name in all the earth. This would be like saying oh
Brandon, our pastor or oh Jenny, my wife. So it's name
and then description. By starting and finishing this claim
David is telling what the psalm is focusing on. So notice that
David didn't say you are majestic in all the earth. He
could have said that but he said your name is majestic in
all the earth. This word name is not talking about God's
name Yahweh. That word could also be translated
reputation. So he's talking about Yahweh's reputation in all
the earth. And David's claim is that God's reputation is
majestic in all the earth. And then David makes a, in the
first part of the psalm David makes a nod to Genesis
chapter one verse one. God creates the heaven and the
earth. So David adds this phrase you have set your
glory above the heavens. So God created the heavens and
the earth and his reputation is glorious and majestic in
all of his creation. Now I think it's also interesting and
this hit me actually last week when Brandon was in the
middle of his lesson. I think I missed about a fourth of
it because all of a sudden this hit me and it's the
way my mind works. But I notice that it says oh Lord,
our Lord. It's not a personal claim that this claim is for
all of us. Oh Lord, our Lord. It's like a proclamation of
truth that David makes. And this is more interesting that
when you look back at the previous five psalms that
we've gone through, the declarations that David
has made were all personal. David said in chapter three
but you, oh Lord, are a shield about me. Oh Lord, my
God, in you do I take refuge. Chapter four, you alone,
oh Lord, make me dwell in safety. So there's
something in this, these earlier psalms where David's
making this, these personal proclamations of faith
in the face of his adversity. But in Psalm eight
he's leading us to make this collective declaration.
Oh Yahweh, our Lord, how majestic is your name in all
the earth. Now it seems to me that these bookend
declarations in the front and back of Psalm eight
suggest that one reads the collection of psalms in
three through fourteen that one might question
God's reputation and that David wants to make it
clear that God's reputation is majestic. So you
know why one might read these and think that God's
reputation is on the line. So again if we think about
God's anointed one, we look at Psalm two, God's
anointed one is going to be this victorious king
but then we see David not so victorious on the
run surrounded by his enemies. One would think, one
might think where, where is Yahweh? Where is
Yahweh to support and save his anointed one?
Now David is clear, Brandon's done a really good job
of showing us that day in all of these Psalms,
even though David was in adversity, he made these
declarations of faith that he knew God was there
for him. But as we read the Psalms and as we go
through life's adversity, sometimes we ask where
is God. In our life as we struggle with
adversity we do. So in the middle of these
bookend declarations of praise, through inspiration
David is going to make this case that God's
majestic reputation is there for us, even in the
face of adversity. So let's dive into this middle
part between these bookend declarations. We'll
see that David's going to make his case in two
sections here. One of them is verse two and the other
is verse three through eight. So let's look at verse
two first. He says, out of the mouth of babies and
infants, you have established strength because of
your foes, you still the enemy and the avenger.
So first of all you see how this, this section
is connected to the previous Psalms. He's talking
about dealing with enemies and foes just like
the adversity that David was experiencing in the
last five Psalms. So we have that connection. But
David says that God's strength in this word here
that's translated strength could be stronghold,
it could be a place, but God's strength will
come from the mouth of babies and infants. It's
like this riddle of, heard it referred to, or
mystery. What is it about infants and babies and
their cry from their mouths that bring strength to
God or bring strength to us? It seems that this
reference to babies and infants is a metaphor and
that the babies and infants are a metaphor for those
that are vulnerable, powerless and weak. So you
can see how again how this connects to this section
here. And so David is using this metaphor of babies
and infants to indicate those who are vulnerable, weak
and powerless. So again remember the first image
I told you, you know rocking your sick baby and
how we viewed the baby as vulnerable and needed
our help, totally dependent on us. But how does
God establish strength through adversity? How does
God establish strength through the vulnerable? It's
kind of a mystery. But we see these truths, the
truth that God works through weakness and
vulnerability and powerless. We see that as a truth
throughout the Bible. Let me just mention a couple
from the New Testament in 2 Corinthians chapter 12.
Paul is talking about his thorn in the flesh, his
weakness. And he says, but he that is God said to
me, my grace is sufficient for you for my power is
made perfect in weakness. Therefore I will boast
all the more gladly of my weakness so that the
power of Christ may rest upon me. For the sake
of Christ then I am content with weakness, insults,
hardships, persecutions and calamities for when I
am weak, then I am strong. And then the passage
from the responsive reading, look at that one if
you don't have that it's in your order of service.
Have you not known? Have you not heard? The Lord
is the everlasting God, the creator of the ends
of the earth. He does not faint or grow weary.
His understanding is unsearchable. He gives
power to the faint. And to him who has no might
he increases strength. Even you shall faint and be
weary and young men shall fall exhausted. But they
who wait on the Lord will renew their strength.
They will mount up with wings like eagles. They
shall run and not be weary. They shall walk
and not faint. So we see that throughout the
Bible from Old and New Testament we see the truth
that we see in Psalm 8. That is through weakness
and vulnerability that there is strength. We see
that it is a truth, but I'll be quick to admit
if you ask me how does that happen? How do we
get strength through less power and weakness
and vulnerability? How does that work? The Bible
clearly says it's a truth, but it's kind of a mystery
about how that happens. But I think we've all
experienced it. Okay, so I think it's worth
mentioning the occasion that Jesus quoted this
passage, this first two in Psalm 8, when Jesus
quoted it. In Matthew chapter 21, this is a
familiar passage to us around Easter time. In
Matthew 21 we describe the occasion of Palm Sunday.
So Jesus rides into Jerusalem, right? He's the
Messiah, the King. He rides in Jerusalem, but
instead of riding in Jerusalem on a victorious
war horse, what does he ride into Jerusalem on?
You see, this is a time I ask for a question
and nobody answers. A donkey! That's right.
He rides in humble on a donkey, right?
So, and who's welcoming him? Is the rich and
powerful welcoming him? No, it's the poor and
the powerless that are welcoming him into
Jerusalem. And they're shouting Hosanna, which
means save me. And immediately after this, Jesus
goes into the temple and he overturns the
tables of the money changers. It's a great example
of Jesus sticking up for the powerless, but we
don't have time to talk about that. And in this
act, Jesus was looking out for the powerless who
were being prevented from worship by the powerful.
So you see how this occasion is consistent
with the message of Psalm 8. And it was on
Jesus's mind as well, because the religious
leaders didn't like the children calling out to
Jesus and saying Hosanna. So they said to Jesus,
you hear what they're saying? And Jesus reminded
them of what Psalm 8 said. In fact, he asked him,
you know what the scripture says? Which was
kind of an insult to them. Jesus reminded them
of what Psalm 8 says, out of the mouth of
infants and nursing babies you have prepared
praise. Now when you look at that and
compare that to Psalm 8 in the Old Testament,
you're going to notice something that we don't
have time to talk about, which is Jesus quotes
it differently. He says, out of the mouth of
infants and nursing babies you have prepared
praise. He doesn't talk about the strength
and enemies and foes. Now the reason for that
is because Jesus is quoting the Greek version
of the Old Testament called the Septuagint.
So 200 years before Jesus was born, since
Greek was the kind of language that everybody
spoke during that time, there were scribes in
Egypt that translated the Hebrew Old Testament
into Greek and it was called the Septuagint.
And anytime you translate, this is the reason
we talk about words in English is because
when we go from Hebrew to English there's
translation issues. Well, every translator has to
make a decision. How do I translate this word
that doesn't have maybe an exact correlation?
So what they did in the Septuagint when they
translated Psalm 8, they translated it like
Jesus spoke it, talking about not strong
strength or stronghold, but about praise.
That's how they translated it.
So what we see is that Jesus seemed to
realize, he seemed to view Psalm 8 as saying
that when the powerless and vulnerable call out
to God, it is a form of praise.
And maybe that's where the strength comes
from. When we call out in praise, we get
strength.
Okay, let's move down to the next section here
in verses 3 through 8.
When I look at your heavens, the work of your
fingers, the moon and the stars which you
have set in place, what is man that you are
mindful of him and the son of man that you
care for him? Yet you have made him a little
lower than the heavenly beings and crowned
him with glory and honor. You have given
him dominion over the works of your hands.
You have put all things under his feet, all
sheep, and oxen and also the beasts of the
field and the birds of the heavens and the
fish of the sea, whatever passes along
the paths of the sea.
So David has taken us back to the creation
story to make his point about God's
reputation. And the words he uses
throughout this section are supposed
to remind the reader of Genesis chapter 1
and what was happened. There are all
kinds of connections to Genesis 1.
Now remember this second image that I
asked you to think about? Standing out,
looking at the night sky, the stars and
the moon and thinking, I'm so small.
I'm so insignificant.
But David tells us here that the
Creator God and his power created the
stars and moon and all the animals
and plants. But in amongst all that
He created humans. These dirt
creatures, right? They came from the dirt
and He raised them up, gave them glory and
honor and made them His images.
Made us His images and gave dominion
over the creation.
So David would want us to think when we
look at the night sky and the stars
and the moon, He wouldn't want us to
think that we're insignificant. David would
want us to think how significant God has
made us and raised us up to be His
partners in this world. So why did
God do that? Why did God take these,
you know, us humans, dirt creatures
and raise us up to be His image
bearers? So I think David uses, in this
Psalm 8 passage, uses two words to
give us an idea of why God made us
image bearers in His partnering with us
in this world, wants us to be His partners
in this world. So look at verse 4. In
the ESV it says, what is man that you
are mindful of Him and the Son of man
that you care for Him? It says God is
mindful and that He cares. Now I want to
look at these two words because the
translation from Hebrew to English
doesn't fully explain the
powerfulness of these two words. So I
want to look at them for a second. I'm
kind of a word nerd, sorry I know
them, but I always see that when I'm
looking at lessons here. First of all
I want to say the Hebrew word here,
man is really human. It's the Hebrew
word for human. So ladies, this is not,
you're not left out of this passage.
Okay? What are humans that you are
mindful of them is really the way that
this would be read because that word is
for humans. Okay, so this first word,
this mindful word, the Hebrew word is
zikar. And most of the time in
Psalm 8 it is translated mindful in
most translations in the ESV, in the
NIV, in the King James it's translated
mindful. In the New American Standard
it's translated take thought instead
of mindful. So this word is used a lot
in the Old Testament. But when we look
how it's translated we see that most
of the time zikar is not translated
mindful. Most of the time it's
translated remember. So we see it's
only translated mindful three times
in the Old Testament. Of all the
times it's used it's only translated
mindful three times. Psalm 8 is one
of them. I can't remember what the
other was. But the third one we're
going to see next week in Psalm 9
where it says Yahweh is mindful of the
afflicted. So it's the same word that
zikar word. So again I said it's used,
this word is used a lot in the Hebrew
Bible so let's look at a few examples.
The first time the word is used in the
Old Testament, the first time zikar is
used is in Genesis 8 with Noah. And it
says that Yahweh remembered Noah. There's
that word zikar. Yahweh remembered Noah
and caused a wind to blow over the earth
and caused the waters to recede. And we
see it used again in Genesis 30 where it
tells us that Yahweh remembered Rachel.
Remember what Rachel's problem was? She
was barren, right? And she couldn't
have children and it says that God
remembered that word zikar. God remembered
her and opened her womb. In Exodus 2 when
Yahweh is explaining why he'll rescue
the Israelites from Egypt, it says that
Yahweh remembered the covenant he made
with Abraham, Isaac, and Jacob. Now this
word zikar is not only used in relation
to God remembering, it also is used
in relation to humans remembering. One of
our Ten Commandments is remember the
Sabbath and keep it holy. That's the same
word, zikar. So what is clear from this
is that this word is meant to convey
a meaning that's not just remembering.
Like, I remember what I did last
Wednesday or I remember your name. That the
word is much stronger than just
remembering something. I'll call it an
actionable remembrance. So in other words
the remembering causes an action. So God
is mindful of us. He remembers us and takes
action towards us. Obviously we've got
lots of fertile ground to talk about how
God takes action in our lives. Obviously
I'll just mention one, Romans 5-6, for
while we were still weak at the right time
Christ died for the ungodly. God remembers
us and he takes action towards us. So now
we have this sense of this mindfulness.
God being mindful of us or remembering us.
Let's look at the second word. For what
is man that you are mindful of him and
the son of man that you care for him? So
in this case the Hebrew word is
pachad is translated cares. And again
most of the time in most translations
it's translated cares. The ESV, the
New American Standard Bers and the NIV.
But King James used a good old English word
visitist. Okay? So visit is a word that
this word is translated into but the
King James turns it into visitist. But
most of the time it's translated into
to cares. Now this word is used many, many
times in the Old Testament. Very common
word and it's translated into a whole
bunch of different words. Just a few of
them. List, like in numbers where it
says it listed all the people in this
particular tribe and there was 34,000
of them. That list word is pachad.
Punishment, appointment, visit, muster,
missed, numbered, commit. I mean it's
just a whole long list of words. So it's
a word that's very pliable. That can be
translated a lot of different ways
translators have. So the Lexham
Theological Dictionary says that the
word means to see to. So if I was to
to see to something that's what this
word would mean. Or to tend to or to
to fulfill an assigned task. That's kind
of what this word pachad means. The
yes, this word is only translated
cares twice. For all the dozens and
dozens, hundreds of times this word is
used. It's only translated cares twice.
And that's here in Psalm 8. And then
there's a one time in Zechariah. So it's
clear that this word in Hebrew doesn't
exactly mean what we traditionally
think of when we use the word care.
Where we think of it like is an
internal feeling of goodwill. It
doesn't mean just that. So let's look
at a few examples. There's a whole
bunch, but let's look at a few
examples. Interesting examples.
Genesis chapter 21 says the Lord
visited, this is the word pachad, the
Lord visited Sarah as he had said and
the Lord did to Sarah as he had
promised. What did he promise? That
she'd have a child, right? Because she
was barren. This theme is going to come
up. Then we have an interesting
example in 1 Samuel. We have Hannah,
who was also barren. And it says that
Yahweh remembered Hannah. That's the
word zikar that we just talked about.
Said that Yahweh remembered Hannah
and opened her womb and she had
Samuel. And then later on in 1 Samuel
it says that Yahweh visited pachad,
our second word from Psalm 8, Hannah,
and she had three more sons. This was
after she was barren. I think, maybe
nobody else thinks it's interesting, but
I think it's very interesting that both
the words that we're looking at here in
Psalm 8 are used in the Hebrew Bible
to describe God's attention to barren
women. Because in their culture,
barren women, they're vulnerable and
powerless and seen as weak, right? But
yet God attends to them. Let's look at
another of references to this word.
Jeremiah chapter 23. I'm bringing this
up because it has both a positive and
negative use of the word. Therefore,
thus says the Lord, the God of Israel,
concerning the shepherds who care
for my people, you have scattered my
flock and have driven them away. You
have not attended, okay, that's the
pachad, it's translated attended, you
have not attended to them. You've not
taken care of them. So God says,
behold, I will attend to you, to the
shepherds, right? So he says you
didn't attend to them, meaning have
some positive care for them. So God
says, I'm going to take care of you,
shepherds, bring judgment on you. So we
see this word as pachad is not just an
internal feeling, but is meant to
describe what I will say detailed and
careful attention toward us. When I try
to think of New Testament passages
that describe the idea of pachad, I
thought of Luke chapter 12 verse 7, are
not five sparrows sold for Jesus
talking, are not five sparrows sold for
two pennies, and not one of them is
forgotten before God? Why even the hairs
of your head are numbered, fear not,
you are more valuable than the sparrows.
The idea that Jesus is telling us that
God has detailed and careful attention
for us, right? Knows the hairs on our
head as many or as few as they are. He
knows us. He knows our thoughts, our
actions, our fears, our worries, our
successes, and our failures. And he has
detailed and careful attention toward
us. I want to mention one last use of
the word pachad because I think it's
very interesting. The Gospel writer,
Luke, is the only Gospel writer that
records what Jesus said when he cried
out the moment of his death. Okay?
It says, then Jesus called out with a
loud voice, Father into your hands I
commit my spirit. And having said this
he breathed his last. Now Jesus was
quoting Psalm 31 which says into your
hand I commit my spirit you have
redeemed me, O Lord faithful God. That
word commit is pachad from Psalm
chapter 8 and from a lot of places.
Okay? So Jesus at the point of the cross
knew that God knew him, saw him, had
detailed attention toward him in this
time. Even in Jesus' worst moment he knew
that God had careful attention to him.
And I hope this gives you comfort that
in your worst moments that God is
giving you careful attention. Okay, so as
we conclude I want to look at a passage
in the New Testament that quotes from
Psalm 8 in Hebrews chapter 2. So let me
read that. It's starting in verse 5.
It has been testified somewhere. What is
man that you are mindful of him and the
son of man that you care for him? You
have made him a little lower than the
angels and you have crowned him with
glory and honor putting everything in
his feet. Now in putting everything in
subjection to him he left nothing outside
his control. At present we do not yet see
everything in subjection to him but we
see him who is a little low, who a little
while was made a little, made lower than
the angels, namely Jesus, crowned with
glory and honor because of the suffering
of death so that by the grace of God
he might taste death for everyone. Now
there's a very, very deep rabbit hole.
And I'm just going to step right over
in this passage. Okay? We just don't have
time to go there. But the writer of
Hebrews seems to validate this idea that
God has raised humans and made us image
bears, gave us dominion over creation.
However there's a comment that's very
interesting here in the area where he
says, at present we do not yet see or
that word can mean appear. At present
we do not yet see everything in
subjection to him, that is humans.
Now I'll admit that there's at least a
couple ways to interpret this phrase. But
I'll say that from my reading it appears
to say that even though humans are
given dominion over creation from
Genesis chapter one in our present
world it just doesn't seem like it
sometimes. The fact is that we are
broken and imperfect image bears in
this world. But what is clear that the
Hebrew writer is saying is that Jesus is
the perfect Son of Man, which the Son of
Man is the phrase that Jesus liked to
refer to himself, that Jesus is the
perfect Son of Man. And that while we
were lifted up by the Creator, Jesus
lowered himself and as an act of
grace subjected himself to the death
on the cross for us. As Philippians two
says that Jesus emptied himself by
taking the form of a servant, being born
in the likeness of man, and being found
in human form, he humbled himself by
becoming obedient to the point of death,
even death on the cross. Therefore God
has highly exalted him and bestowed him
the name that is above every name so
that the name of Jesus, every knee
should bow in heaven and on earth and
under the earth, and every tongue
confess that Jesus Christ is Lord to
the glory of God the Father. I was
working in the yard yesterday. That
probably wouldn't surprise anybody here
who knows us very well. Working in the
yard yesterday. And I typically am
listening to something, podcast or, you
know, a sermon we missed or, but this
case I was listening to music and a
song came on and usually I'm, you know,
the days before my lesson is just kind
of, you know, ruminating in my head
thinking about it. Yesterday I happened to
be listening to some music and a song
from my like list started playing and
I was thinking about this lesson and I
realized this song that I was listening
to was describing the ideas of Psalm 8
very well. The song is
probably familiar to many of you, is
Better Than a Hallelujah by Amy
Grant. Okay? Does that sound familiar?
So listen to the lyrics. God loves a lullaby
in a mother's tears in the dead of
night better than a hallelujah sometimes.
God loves the drunkard's cry. The
soldiers plea not to let him die.
Better than a hallelujah sometimes. We
pour out our miseries. God just hears
a melody. Beautiful the mess we are.
The honest cries of breaking hearts are
better than a hallelujah. The woman
holding on for life, the dying man
giving up the fight are better than a
hallelujah sometimes. The tears of
shame for what's been done, the silence
when the words won't come are better
than a hallelujah sometimes. We pour
out our miseries. God just hears a
melody. Beautiful the mess we are. The
honest cries of breaking hearts are
better than a hallelujah. From what we
know from our own lives is that we can
sometimes identify with David as we
cry out to God. In Psalm 3 to 7 we see
that David was chased and surrounded by
his enemies. But we're also sometimes
chased and surrounded. But sometimes
it's just the difficulties of life that
we struggle with. Family difficulties,
health problems, financial problems, the
list can go on and on. Sometimes we feel
surrounded. And it affects us all.
Maybe this is where you are and I'm
sure it's where we've all been at
times. But the message of Psalm 8 is
that our cries when we are weak and
powerless and vulnerable result in our
strength and praise towards God. So
keep pouring out your miseries because
God just hears a melody. Let's pray.
Dear God, we thank you so much for this
passage. Thank you for our time together
and pray that you will give us strength
when we are weak and vulnerable and
sometimes just don't know where to turn.
But we know thankfully that we can
turn to you for deliverance and for
comfort and that you know us and that
you remember us. In Jesus' name, amen.